bonjour à tous et à toutes mercredi 13
juin c'est la finale de ma thèse en 180
secondes
et pour l'occasion on accueille davina
des ce plan selon prix du jury 2010 est
pour nous parler d'émulsion la
spécialité à moi ce sont les crèmes
hydratantes et en ces périodes de
chaleur estivale une équipe de
chercheurs a décidé de congés makrem ben
les gars ça va par là je fais pu la
sortir du pot l'équipe de chercheurs de
cavaillon et de paris souhaite observer
le comportement des missions lors de
leur population
petit rappel l'émission et la dispersion
de gouttes d'huile dans de l'eau comme
une vinaigrette une mayonnaise ou une
crème hydratante
par contre ma crème hydratante est bien
plus efficace sur la peau faites moi
confiance
alors vous me direz si on veut
comprendre comment se passe la
congélation d'une émulsion il suffit
d'un film et pendant qu on la refroidit
oui mais le problème est bien plus
compliqué que ça car pour bien voir le
phénomène de congélation
il faut regarder à l'échelle
microscopique et à cette échelle tout se
passe très rapidement
c'est pourquoi les chercheurs ont
utilisé la microscopie confocale une
technique d'imagerie particulièrement
bien adapté à ce genre d'expérience et
regarder les images qu'ils obtiennent
[Musique]
on
wahou ses pistes aux canons alors non il
ne s'agit pas de choquer neige qui tombe
sur les toits ni d'un fond d'écran
windows mais bel et bien de vraies
images de frais microscopie obtenu par
de vrais chercheurs dans un vrai
laboratoire avec une fausse mayonnaise
les chercheurs ont utilisé différents
colorants pour pouvoir bien observer ce
qu'il se passe
les petites gouttes d'huile c'est ce
qu'on voit en bleu clair en magenta
c'est l'eau liquide et la zone bleue
très foncée voire quasi noir correspond
à la glace la caméra est positionné
juste au dessus de ce qu'on appelle le
front de solidification ce ne sont pas
les gouttes qui tombent mais bien la
glace qui se rapprochent d'elle et
l'image reste centrée sur la limite aux
glaces c'est la première fois qu'on
obtient des images en temps réel de ce
processus et voilà ce qu'on observe ont
pu remarquer un léger ralentissement au
niveau du front de solidification en
réalité lorsque la goutte les d'huile va
entrer en contact avec la glace
informations elle va être retenu à
l'interface ogla jusqu'à un certain
temps avant d'être engloutis ce temps
est appuyé le temps de l'interaction les
chercheurs ont pu montrer que ce temps
dépend directement de la vitesse de
croissance des cristaux de glace lorsque
les crises au delà se forment encore
plus lentement
les gouttelettes d'huile soit rejetée
par la glace et commencent à former de
petits agrégats et c'est justement ce
que l'on souhaite éviter lorsque le
congèle notre émulsion pour comprendre
plus en détail le phénomène ils se sont
ensuite intéressés à ce qu'il se passe
au niveau de la gouttelette quand elle
est en présence de glace 1 2 3 soleil
ici les chercheurs ont pu mettre en
évidence la formation d'un film liquide
représenté en orange autour de la
gouttelette ce film contient de l'eau et
des molécules qui permet de stabiliser
l'émulsion on les appelle les
tensioactifs car elles réduisent les
tensions entre l'eau et l'huile qui se
détestent un petit peu quand même
beaucoup en fait je dirais même que les
tensioactifs sont des dalaï lama qui
amène la paix dans l'émulsion
les chercheurs ont donc procédé à un
recensement des ces molécules pacifistes
et se soit rendu compte qu'elle avait
tendance à s'accumuler au front de
solidification selon le chercheur les
tensions actifs seraient au nombre de
cent mille réunit aujourd'hui sur le
fond de solidification alors que la
police annonce plutôt un nombre de 5000
molécules présentes entre l'eau et lui
ce sont donc les relations initiée par
ces molécules pacifistes qui détermine
l'harmonie l'organisation finale de
l'émulsion congelés les chercheurs ont
ainsi pu mettre en évidence l'importance
ces molécules dans l'intégration des
goudjil dans leur nouvel environnement
glace et on observe que les tensioactifs
en orange se concentrent localement
autour de la gouttelette pendant son
grossissement
[Musique]
finalement ce qui est plutôt cool dans
tout ça c'est que les résultats obtenus
avec une émulsion du type o l'huile
tension actives peuvent être transposées
à d'autres systèmes complexes
on peut ainsi comprendre plus finement
les interactions qui entrent en jeu dans
la production d'alliages en métallurgie
mais aussi améliorer la cryoconservation
de cellules tels que les globules rouges
les spermatozoïdes en préservant mieux
leurs fonctionnalités voilà pour habitat
mais cela chez vous il ne vous reste
plus qu'à faire une petite mayonnaise et
trouver un microscope confocal on vous
invite à suivre la finale de ma thèse en
180 secondes l'histoire de se remettre
de toutes ces émotions ces émotions et
abonnez vous